نحن نؤمن بالمساواة ونؤمن
بالإنسانية ونعتقد أن الدنمارك
مرة أخرى يجب أن تكون بلدًا إنسانيًا
عندما يتعلق الأمر باللاجئين والمهاجرين والأقليات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شكرًا لك بلد أجنبي
[موسيقى
] أحد أفضل البلدان  في
العالم
ولكن للأسف على مدار العشرين عامًا الماضية
، شهدنا بيئة معادية للإسلام
في الدنمارك السياسية
ولهذا السبب أنشأنا
سلالات مستقلة لأننا أقوى الأولاد
في السياسة الدنماركية
عندما يتعلق الأمر بحقوق الأقليات والأقليات
[الموسيقى]
[موسيقى]
أجنبية وكونك ديمقراطيًا
، من الضروري الدفاع عن
حقوق
الفلسطينيين والإخوة والأخوات الفلسطينيين لأن
ما تفعله إسرائيل غير مقبول
وللأسف المجتمع الدولي
يراقب ما تفعله إسرائيل في هذا البلد
الصغير.